guten Morgen Tina Dauster liebe
Zuschauer liebe Zuschauer bevor es aber
hier zur Gas und strompreisbremsen
Verabschiedung kommt ein wichtiges
Vorhaben das nahezu jeden bei uns
betrifft gibt es noch einen Festakt im
Bundestag für 30 Minuten so viel Zeit
will man sich nehmen es gibt nämlich
zwei Jubiläen zu feiern
vorgestern vor 50 Jahren am 13 dezember
1972 wurde zum ersten Mal in Deutschland
eine Frau als Bundestagspräsidentin
gewählt annemarie Renger von der SPD die
SPD hatte die Bundestagswahl 1972
gewonnen wurde zum ersten Mal stärkste
Fraktion und stellte die
Bundestagspräsident daraus zu schließen
dass die SPD auch damals schon eine Hort
der Frauenversteher ist das ist
allerdings falsch
Annemarie länger hat später süffisant
erzählt ich habe mich in der Fraktion
selbst für das Amt des der
Bundestagspräsidentin vorgeschlagen
glauben sie sonst die hätten mich
genommen
war 1972 weltweit auch die einzige Frau
die Präsidentin eines frei gewählten
Parlaments war im Jahre 2008 ist sie
hoch verehrt hoch angesehen im Alter von
fast 89 Jahren verstorben der andere
Jubilar der ist heute anwesend am
gleichen Tag an dem Annemarie Renner zur
Bundestagspräsidentin gewählt worden ist
am 13 dezember 1972 war sein erster
offizieller Arbeitstag als Abgeordneter
30 Jahre jung Wahlkreis Offenburg hört
auf den Namen Wolfgang Schäuble Wolfgang
Schäuble hat eine beispiellose
politische Karriere hingelegt mit Höhen
und Tiefen wie wir wissen er hat nahezu
alle politischen Spitzenämter bekleidet
mit Ausnahme das Amts des
Bundespräsidenten und des Bundeskanzlers
aber auch in diesen beiden Ämtern ist er
relativ knapp vorbeigeschrammt er ist
der dienstälteste Abgeordnete in der
Geschichte nationaler deutscher
Parlamente das gilt sowohl für den
Bundestag wie auch für den Reichstag
dafür wird er auch geehrt nachher ab 9
Uhr bis 9:30 Uhr und 9:30 Uhr kommt dann
das wichtigste Thema wo das heutigen
Tages die Verabschiedung der Strom und
gaspreisbremse und dazu zu diesem
politischen Teil gibt's auch das
Interview gesehen bei uns äh
stellvertretende Vorsitzende der
Fraktion die Linken und gleicher
Funktion bei der FDP Lutz Köder
Entschuldigung Lukas Köhler Frau lütsch
das erste Gesetzesvorhaben mit dem alle
restlos zufrieden sind
aber können sie denn der Strom- und
Gaspreis wenn sie etwas Positives
abgewinnen wir sind natürlich nicht
restlos zufrieden und wir werden auch
nicht zustimmen sondern uns enthalten
die größte Schwierigkeit oder das größte
Problem dieses Gesetzes ist ja das ist
sozial völlig unausgewogen ist es wird
erstattet nach Verbrauch der Vorjahre
bzw ungedeckelt aber zum Beispiel jemand
der in einer kleinen Einzimmerwohnung
wohnt oder in einer kleinen Mietwohnung
und sowieso schon immer gespart hat die
muss man mal erklären wo er noch weiter
sparen soll und warum er nicht 100%
erstattet bekommt jemand der in einer
großen Villa wohnt vielleicht noch eine
Sauna hat und Swimmingpool den er
beheizt bekommt auch erstattet und das
ist total ungerecht zumal es ja aus
unserer Steuergeld kommt und im
kommenden Jahr wieder die Schuldenbremse
angezogen werden soll das heißt dann
dann wird überall im sozialen Bereich
gespart für uns ist das nicht innehmbar
äh Lukas Köhler wer viel Energie
verbraucht so dass ich das leisten kann
der würde auch besonders stark entlastet
ist auch gerade schon angedeutet gibt es
da eine soziale Schieflage in dem
Gesetzesvorhaben nein also ich glaube es
gibt keine soziale Schieflage per se wir
sehen ja das bei der gaspreisbremse eben
genau diese Frage schon geklärt wird
dadurch dass wir eben die Besteuerung
einführen und wir haben ja einen sehr
starken Steuersatz auch für diejenigen
die viel Geld verdienen und damit auch
viel Steuern zahlen genauso wird auch
der Steuersatz hier angewandt damit
glaube ich auch nicht dass es eine
soziale Schieflage gibt um aber
natürlich dafür zu sorgen dass die
Menschen entlastet werden dies besonders
hart getroffen haben dieses Jahr führen
wir neben den Bremsen auch noch die
härtefallfonds ein ähm in diversesten
Bandbreiten und versuchen da auch den
Menschen wirklich über das über die
Härten die durch diesen Krieg den Putin
gegen uns führt auf Energie Seite
wirklich auszugleichen die nächste Frage
ist möglicherweise für den heutigen
Berliner morgen mit -8 Grad etwas
unpassen aber es gibt ja auch wieder
wärmere Perioden im Winter ist der
subventionierte Anteil der Energie die
wir jetzt haben also 80 Prozent der
Privathaushalte 70% haben die
Unternehmen generell zu hoch weil
einfach zu wenig Energie eingespart wird
am letzten Sonntag sind ein Prozent der
gesamten Energie der Gasvorräte in
Deutschland verbraucht worden ich kann
nur noch mal bekräftigen das ist da eine
soziale Schieflage gibt gerade Menschen
die wenig Geld haben wohnen in schlecht
isolierten Häusern das heißt selbst wenn
sie die Heizung unter Null drehen würden
was ja gar nicht möglich ist können sie
nicht weiter sparen und ich muss auch
dem Argument widersprechen dass das
Steuersystem das alles aus regelt die
Steuer Mehreinnahmen die jetzt
eingeplant werden durch die Abschöpfung
von sogenannten übergewinnen die
gleichen mit nichten das aus was für die
Bremsen aus dem steueraus genau aber ich
will es noch mal deutlich sagen was aus
dem steuersäcke bezahlt wird und die ist
Steuergeld gehört ja allen sollte allen
zu Gute kommen und wird sehr ungleich
verteilt und die FDP hat sich wieder
sehr entschlossen durchgesetzt in der
Koalition ich kann sie nur wieder als
Vermögensverwalter der Reichen
bezeichnen gut ob das ist wenn wir jetzt
bei der nächsten Frage gleich sehen
Energie intensive Unternehmen den
draußen ist ja vor der nächsten Zeit
einige oder viele rechnen sogar mit
einer Insolvenz sind die
unternehmenshilfen für die ja auch die
FDP der Ampel verantwortlich ist
wirklich zielgenau ich glaube gerade bei
den Unternehmen sehen wir dass wir viel
tun und tun müssen weil wir müssen
natürlich auch für Arbeitsplätze sorgen
die Leute haben jetzt wirklich Sorge
gehabt lange Zeit davor wie geht's mit
der wirtschaftlichen Entwicklung weiter
wie sie wirklich die Inflation aber auch
diese Krise aus und wir sorgen mit den
Geldern die wir in die Hand nehmen
wirklich dafür dass kleine
mittelständische aber auch große
Unternehmen in Deutschland ihre
Arbeitsplätze erhalten dass sie dafür
sorgen dass sie auch wieder reden
investieren all das haben wir jetzt in
dieses Paket gepackt und ist auch gut
und richtig so und ich glaube wir sehen
auch natürlich mit diesem Instrument
dass wir in der Breite helfen klar ist
nicht alles gegen finanziert durch die
Steuereinnahmen über der
strompreisbremse das war auch nie das
Ziel in so einer Krise in einem Krieg
der gegen uns geführt wird müssen wir
auch als Staaten unterstützen deswegen
haben wir diese 200 Milliarden
aufgenommen und über den Wirtschaft
stabilisierungsform schütten wir das
Geld aus das hilft den Unternehmen das
hilft dabei diesen Standort zu erhalten
und es sorgt dafür dass die Menschen gut
über höchste Zeit kommen und das ist das
was der Ampel wichtig ist bei dem
Unternehmensbereich noch kühler
Unternehmen die staatliche
Stützungsmaßnahmen bekommen die werden
bei der Auszahlung von Dividenden und
Boni entweder eingeschränkt oder es wird
ganz verboten da war die FDP aber nicht
dafür das war ihnen eigentlich nicht
recht dieser Kompromiss ist ja in
letzter im letzten Moment noch
geschlossen worden warum
kriegen Unternehmen die auch vom Staat
und für Steuerzahler unterstützt werden
sollen auch noch Dividenden und Boni
bekommen jedenfalls die die Spitzen
Leute in diesem Unternehmen da muss ich
Ihnen widersprechen ganz klar weil die
Haushälter haben in ihrem
maßgabenschluss Beschluss zum Wirtschaft
und stabilisierungs vor ja schon vor
einiger Zeit als quasi das Geld
aufgenommen wurde und meines Wissens
nach sind das alle Haushälter nämlich
auch die ampelhaushälter als auch unsere
schon dafür gesorgt dass klar gemacht
wurde das Wohnen und die wieder
rausgenommen werden ab und Sie haben
richtig beschrieben ab zwei Hüllen
einmal 25 Millionen Euro mehr als 25
Millionen Euro Bremsen Unterstützung des
Staates bekommt der kann für seine
spitzen Leute keine Boni aus und ab 50
Millionen Euro Unterstützung gibt es
keine Boni und Dividenden das waren
Kompromiss den bei uns die Haushälter
miteinander vereinbart haben und dem
hinter dem stehen wir ganz genauso wie
der Rest der Ampel ich muss da ein
bisschen korrigieren in der Tat wir
haben das ja gestern im
Haushaltsausschuss besprochen und
beschlossen es gibt zwei Stufen aber bei
den 25 Millionen ist es so dass die Boni
und Dividenden im Vergleich zum vorher
nicht erhöht werden dürfen also sie
dürfen weiterhin ausgezahlt werden das
heißt Unternehmen die mit
steuerzahlermitteln subventioniert
werden dürfen weiter ihre Spitzen Leute
hoch bezahlen und das ist natürlich auch
ungerecht und das merken ja die Leute
die erleben dass wir den größten real
lohnverlust seit Bestehen der
Bundesrepublik haben die Löhne steigen
zwar aber die Inflation ist viel viel
schneller und darum muss man genau auf
diese Fragen besonders schauen
widersprechen aber also Dividenden
erstmal haben gar nichts mit den Spitzen
Geld an zu tun sondern da geht es um die
Substanz der Unternehmen wenn wir jetzt
großflächig gesagt hätten und 50
Millionen ist viel das stimmt weil das
ja die Hilfen sind nicht das was das
Unternehmen einnimmt sondern in den
Hilfen wenn wir das jetzt rausgenommen
hätten dann würden wir dafür sorgen dass
es ein Ausverkauf deutscher Firmen in
Deutschland gebe und bei den Boni das
ist nun mal Teil ganz oft auch der
Gehälter übrigens nicht nur der
Spitzengehälter sondern von dem
mittleren Management den Leuten aus der
Mittelschicht in Deutschland die darüber
ihr Gehalt bestimmen und deswegen muss
man sehr sehr vorsichtig sein wenn man
daran rangeht klar ist auch wenn wir
wirklich große staatliche Summen in die
Hand nehmen dass wir dann da vorsichtig
sind und sagen na ja das kann jetzt
nicht aufgrund der staatlichen bitte
noch mal erhöht werden bzw muss
ausgeschlossen werden ist klar aber man
muss da glaube ich sehr zielgerichtet
bleiben darf ich da mal noch ansetzen
ohne Dividenden sind bei den Linken
nicht sehr beliebt aber wir reden ja im
Moment ja nicht von
internationalen Großkonzernen wo die
Spitzenmanager auf ihre Millionen
Gehälter noch oben was drauf kriegen
sondern ist war ja zu hören dass zum
Beispiel in den Familienunternehmen die
Unternehmerinnen und Unternehmer ein
Großteil ihres Einkommens über solche
Dividenden beziehen was machen wir in
dem Fall wenn gleichzeitig die
Unternehmen weil sie in wirtschaftliche
Schwierigkeiten geraten
dann auch diese Dividenden ja eigentlich
auszahlen müssten müssen dann die
Familienunternehmer auf Gehalt
verzichtenden Zeit lang also ich finde
den Begriff Familienunternehmen die muss
man sich mal genauer anschauen
normalerweise denkt man ja so im
umgangssprachlichen Gebrauch das ist der
Bäckermeister an der Ecke oder eine
kleine Schneiderei oder ein Friseursalon
aber unter dem Oberbegriff
Familienunternehmen verstecken sich ja
in Deutschland solche Familien wie
Quandt und Platten die also BMW führen
und andere und da wäre mir an einer
Differenzierung das war glaube ich nicht
gemeint sondern in der Tat eher der
erste Fall den sie genannt haben aber
dafür werden sie für Differenzierung
natürlich bin ich für die
Differenzierung und natürlich ist es ein
ganz wichtiger Punkt Arbeitsplätze zu
erhalten und in dem Gesetz ist mir auch
viel zu wenig an Arbeitsplatzsicherheit
geregelt es wird gesagt Unternehmen die
Unterstützung erhalten vom Staat müssen
bis 2024 90% der Arbeitsplätze erhalten
aber was ist denn nach 20 24 und wir
haben ja wirklich böse Erfahrung mit dem
Wirtschaft Stabilisierungsfonds in der
coronakrise Stichwort Lufthansa da wurde
das Geld
rausgeschmissen wieder zurückgezahlt das
ist richtig aber ganz ganz viele
Arbeitsplätze sind verloren gegangen und
das darf natürlich in dieser Situation
überhaupt nicht der Fall sein ich will
aber noch mal das Stichwort Krieg
aufgreifen weil das Herr Köhler ja
mehrfach in den Mund genommen hat wir
müssen doch alles tun um
wirtschaftskriege zu beenden oder zu
vermeiden wir sind im Augenblick in
einer Lage dass wir in der
Auseinandersetzung sind mit Russland wir
sind in der Auseinandersetzung mit China
mit den Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika
und da brauchen wir eine langfristige
Konzeption und ich sehe bei der Ampel im
Augenblick nur
kurzfristig und die USA miteinander
vergleichen ist völlig absur tut mir
leid dass ich die geht
einfach nicht
widersprechensverbrecher wie Putin
einknicken um Gottes Willen auf keinen
Fall wir müssen doch aus der Geschichte
lernen wir hatten eine einseitige
Abhängigkeit von Russland von der CDU
und von der SPD damals organisiert über
die vielen Jahre der großen Koalition
und jetzt müssen wir uns davon bewahren
in eine nächste einseitige abhäng
Möglichkeit zu kommen zum Beispiel habe
ich war in Katar hat sich dort verneigt
vor den Scheichs also wir können doch
nicht von den einen Oligarchen zu den
anderen olligarchen wechseln sondern wir
brauchen vielfältige
wirtschaftsbeziehung in alle Richtungen
in viele Richtung und wir dürfen uns
nicht von einem abhängig machen ich
würde gerne zur Strom- und Gaspreise
zurückkehren Köhler es geht um die
Wirksamkeit des Gesetzes wie können sie
denn verhindern dass die Energieerzeuger
das ja gerade schon angesprochen worden
angesichts der doch starken staatlichen
Subventionen bei den Tarifen jetzt noch
eine Schippe drauflegen nach dem Motto
der Zahl der Stadt zahlt ja ihn gibt
drei Stellen wo wir explizit Missbrauch
ausschließen dass eines wir frieren den
Grundbetrag sozusagen ein ab auf den
September diesen Jahres wo noch nicht
klar war welche Art von von Hilfen und
Bremsen kommen und das glaube ich auch
richtig dafür dass wir dass wir dafür
sorgen dass nur noch in Notfällen oder
nur noch wenn es wirklich begründete
Ausnahmen gibt dieser Grundtarif
angepasst werden kann das ist sozusagen
verhindert diese Frage von ihm zum
zweiten haben wir natürlich einen
eigenen Paragrafen nochmal geschaffen um
missbräuchlichkeiten missbräuchliche
die Nutzung dieser Bremsen zu verändern
zu verhindern auch über das Kartellamt
dass das überprüft und der dritte
Schritt ist dass wir der mit der
gemeinsamen als Bundestag und
Bundesregierung dafür sorgen können über
eine Verordnung dass wir an anderen
Stellen noch mal anpassen wenn wir
merken dass es missbräulichkeiten gibt
klar ist auch das ist ein ganz neues
Instrument klar ist auch das ist jetzt
gerade in dieser Situation neu
geschaffen und man kann nicht ein
perfektes Gesetz machen und alle Fehler
schon ausgeräumt haben deswegen müssen
wir schnell reagieren können dafür haben
wir gesorgt wir müssen aber auf jeden
Fall ein einfaches schnelles und
wirksames Instrument schaffen das haben
wir mit dieser Gas und der Strompreis
Bremse jetzt vorgelegt und dafür damit
können wir dafür sorgen dass die Härten
wirklich ausgeglichen werden und im
Zweifel nach Steuern können zu den
Härten ist ein Punkt der völlig fehlt
das ist das Verbot von Strom und
gasperren und das war haben wir als
LINKE immer wieder gefordert das hätte
in diesem Gesetz stehen müssen das heißt
also das hat ja auch damit zu tun das
ist auch ein Moderatorin glaube ich für
Mieten geben soll das eine Miete nicht
mehr bezahlt hat oder bezahlen kann im
im Winter das er dann auch entsprechend
nicht gekündigt werden kann wird sich da
die Ampel noch bewegen wir haben mit der
mit den aktuellen Hilfen das sind ja
nicht nur diese 200 Milliarden sondern
die 96 Milliarden die wir dieses Jahr
schon ausgeschüttet haben wo viel Geld
jetzt bei den Menschen angekommen ist
dafür gesorgt dass wir die Härten dieses
Krieges auseinander
aufhalten dass wir dafür sorgen dass die
Menschen unterstützt sind dass Sie gut
durch den Winter kommen und die
Diskussion zu mieten Moratorien oder dem
schweren von Gas und strompreisbremsen
ist eine lang geführte aber hat mit
diesem Thema jetzt erstmal selber nichts
zu tun weil wir jetzt den Menschen
wirklich helfen können für die
Betroffenen ist es aber sehr wichtig
meine Position ist kann sie nur noch mal
wiederholen Strom und Gaspreis werden
müssen verboten werden wir können noch
lange drüber reden das geht aber nicht
mehr das klingen zeigen heißt ab ins
Parlament es geht gleich los mit dem
Festakt und danach mit dem Thema
deswegen ich gesprochen hat mit Gesine
Lötzsch und mit Lukas Köhler vielen Dank
dass sie da waren